i am very excited about your movie i
have to lead with that it's also very
lovely to meet you
but that just energized me so much um
i'm very excited i can't wait for it and
it all started this is what i love
everything started from you tweeting
this tweet in 2014
hey marvel great job with captain
america and thor
now how about an asian-american hero so
did you have
any expectations after that tweet of
maybe them possibly reaching out
um yeah yeah for sure you know i tweeted
uh in you know 2014
and i was like uh like a struggling
actor i was handing out dog food samples
on the side of the road in toronto and i
was like yeah i'm gonna tweet marvel and
it's gonna be great they're gonna
you know read the tweet get back to me
offer me a role and so basically
everything's worked out as planned and
uh
that's amazing years later right now
absolutely no idea it was going to
happen and it was just kind of a
facetious thing that i tweeted
and um you know it's what's happening in
these next few years has just been
pretty incredible and pretty insane so
i'm still pinching myself every day to
be honest
um but after getting the part um you
replied to your own tweet lol
which was awesome you're like
hey you know what i am noticing um
almost to the day actually it was july
17th and i was like i was cast on july
21st oh my god crazy that works out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever